namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma-sambhodasa namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma-sambhodasa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa homage to the buddha the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one okay so we're celebrating the moon night actually i think it's on wednesday but uh we have to uh bend the rules a bit for our culture so we're doing it tonight
And the topic is on karma and rebirth.
So just going through the sort of basics really, just being sure as to what we mean by personal karma.
In other words, the karma that leads to liberation.
So we understand in Buddhism that there are five laws, the first one being
the law of heat that's how it translates um but it's really to do with what we would call physics and chemistry just matter so those are laws which are separate from personal uh personal responsibility now what i'm really what i think is really pointing to here is things like the tsunami
So in the East, if you were a victim of the tsunami, they would tend to think that was because in some past life you must have drowned somebody or something worse.
So it gets a bit far-fetched.
So we have to be clear that the Earth matter has its own properties, and we happen to be born at this time.
Now, there is this connection, of course, with climate change, but that comes later.
The next one is hereditary.
If you're born with a disease coming from your parents and their parents and back all the way, that's not your personal karma.
That's to do with being born with that certain genetic makeup.
now what is your personal karma is how you relate to it and again we'll come to that in a minute so it's uh to think of somebody who is who's born say with uh down syndrome and to think that they are therefore must have been uh some sort of uh animal in the past life and that they're born at the same level of intelligence that wouldn't be that wouldn't be correct okay even they have their own karma to work out
the next one would be uh chitta so this is our psychology so we're born with a certain set of psychological rules and that's as simple as that a simple one would be just the way we learn language and that's all to do with the mind the wake up of the mind and the brain so
Remember, in the Buddha's teaching, the mind and the body are two separate energy systems.
And when we're reborn, it's the mind that leaves the body.
And we'll come to that again when we have just a quick reminder of what rebirth is.
So again, you have to be very careful when we're talking about personal karma, the karma that leads to liberation or not.
It's the opposite way too.
And this leads us to the problem of social karma.
So a lot of people might talk about social karma, meaning the karma of, say, being born in British culture or in another culture.
And again, that wouldn't be quite the way that the Buddha would see it.
He would see it more as a collection of individuals.
And the collection of individuals have agreed to certain rules and regulations, certain cultural norms.
Most of this is passed on to us, whether we like it or not, when we're children.
it's not as though it's something that is out there as as a social or as something separate from from individuals right the the whatever is passed on to us through our societies is passed on individually through our parents through through the media and so on and so forth so again it's about individuals and it's the same when we
You know, when you think about, say, thousands of deaths from famine or thousands of deaths from all these conflicts that are going on, all that really is individuals who are dying.
And some will die very peacefully, some will not have suffered greatly, and others, of course, will have died in agony.
But again, it's all very individual.
It's our universe, right?
So if you think about it, everything that we're experiencing is coming in through the senses and through our own particular conditioning, and what we're experiencing now is our own little universe, and we're always at the center of it.
So when somebody steps into that universe and does us harm, that isn't our personal karma, that's coming from their decision-making.
Our personal karma is how we react.
So that takes us into the next section about karma itself, the law of karma.
And this is all about ethics.
And you could say that the Buddha really, you know, you could reduce all his teachings to ethics and transcendence.
And the reason for that, remember, is that because of this delusion that we are suffering from, we enter into a wrong relationship.
So when we look at our ethical, moral behavior, that will be a measure of our wisdom or lack of it.
So there's a connection there between the process of liberation and ethics.
So there's always this purification has to go on at the same time as insight.
You can't have insight and still go around murdering people and robbing from them and getting wild on drugs.
It's not possible, right?
because of the connection between the delusion and how it manifests and the process of beginning to undermine that delusion through the process of ethical behavior and that's all put out of course in the eightfold path you know right speech right action right livelihood
And the more we work on that, the more it sort of feeds back into the way that we understand the world.
So that karma, when we talk about the Lord of Karma, we're talking really about ethics.
And that's now beginning to be where our...
Well, the core work is, you might say.
The final one is to do with Dharma.
And these are, of course, the basic teachings of the Buddha, the Four Noble Truths, the law of karma itself, and wheel of dependent origination, dependent origination itself too.
So all that teaching of the Buddha comes under the law of the Dharma.
The Dharma itself is the truth that will, when we take it on, will lead us to the end of our own personal inner suffering.
So remember, the suffering we're talking about is to do with wrong understanding.
So it doesn't include physical suffering.
So long as we have a body, it's going to give us pain.
It's just the way it is.
But the heart, once cleansed of all its negativity, of all its unwholesome habits and understandings, begins to be in a state of one of the four great illimitables, one of the four brahmaviharas.
It's in some state of love or some state of compassion, some state of joy or just peaceful equanimity.
That's the Buddha heart.
But don't confuse that with the Buddha itself, the Buddha within, which is this pure awareness.
Remember, the awareness is within this psychophysical organism.
And it's through this organism that it's manifesting its delusion or its wisdom.
Okay.
that's the dharma so uh the point here is to be very clear as to what is our personal karma the karma that leads to either continued rebirth or to uh liberation and it all comes back to the dependence origination and to the point of
reaction to what we're experiencing right and that's uh oh just a minute i don't know what this is thank you very much that's a bit of an interruption from uh from dell can't help it you know it's just one of those things um
So dependent origination, what it's saying is that this tanha, this wrong relationship to things that we call attachment, indulgence, aversion, fear, all these sorts of reactions to what we are experiencing is the cause of our unsatisfactoriness, our suffering and our continued suffering.
And it's when we undermine that, that we begin to roll that wheel backwards upon itself, and we come down to the root problem, which is about our sense of identity.
That's where the root is.
Remember, his victory verse is that he had discovered the house builder.
and he's broken down, he's fined the house builder, he's broken the house, he's broken this and he's broken that, it all sounds very violent, and he's liberated himself, he's found the citta, that knowing which is the Buddha within.
So that's the root problem as to what we identify with.
And remember that when you are practicing vipassana, you've pulled yourself out of this organism into this observer.
And that observer really recognizes it as a place of untouchability.
Once you're established there, nothing can harm you.
Really sort of grasp that because that's very close to our liberation.
So when it comes to something like rebirth, it's not within our culture.
It's a bit difficult for us to sort of get our head around that.
The fact that we might be reborn into another place, another time, take on a different personality.
And yet through that personality, whatever unwholesomeness and wholesomeness we have in terms of the way we look at things will again begin to manifest.
So really, for those that find it just difficult to accept, it's a case of just putting it on the back burner.
I mean, there'll come a point when we'll know for sure, right?
And that's when we leave the planet.
So there's no point in rushing the decision.
The decision will be made for us when we die.
And if after all it's just annihilation, we just disappear, well, there's no problem in that at all, is there?
I mean, there's no suffering involved in that whatsoever.
So it's best not to come to a decision about that.
There's no need, for instance, to come to a conclusion.
If we don't have that information, and we're talking about information which is experiential, this is not science, we're never going to prove it with a thermometer or something, it's just something which is beyond our ability to know in that sort of way.
But there are people who have
come out of the body and have gone to such places and they stand as witness to that possibility so really it's just the case of keeping it as a as a possibility yeah um i mean in the fullness of the teaching it gives you some idea of uh the grand moral
laws that go right through the cosmos through all the through all the different levels of being there is this law of karma which is basically saying if you're coming from a wrong place you're going to end up unhappy if you're coming from a deluded place you're going to keep finding yourself in in an unhappy situation
And slowly it's going to come through to you that maybe you're the problem.
It isn't the other person who's making you angry.
The world doesn't make you depressed.
There's something within us which is causing it.
And there's some resolution, you might say, to the whole problem of moral behavior.
But again, it always comes down to the individual.
So whether samsara will ever come to an end is anybody's guess.
As individuals keep reappearing, they themselves are their own little universe working out their own plan.
And eventually, in Buddhist understanding again, liberation is a, what's the word, it's
It has to happen.
It's within the process.
I can't think of the word.
It's something which is set into the process because that part of us which is deluded is not naturally deluded.
Itself is clear of delusion.
What it is, is a simple not knowing.
So in itself it is absolutely pure and whole, but because of this misunderstanding it finds itself creating this bad karma, these bad consequences, unwholesome consequences, the suffering.
And it can pull itself out and return to its original purity, otherwise there'd be no escape.
So that's what the Buddha says in one of these little verses about the process, there is an unborn,
There is an undying, there's something that doesn't die.
There is an unconditioned.
And then he says, if it were not so, there would not be an escape from what is born and dies and is conditioned.
Yeah.
So there's hope for us all.
This is the big message, right?
So no matter how miserable we become, there is an end.
So we have to accept that.
I mean, he's up there on his pedestal and he's definitely teaching us that.
So I can only hope my words have been of some assistance, that they have not caused any confusion, and that you will, by your careful ethical behavior, release yourself from all suffering sooner rather than later.